à partir de demain s'ouvrira à Paris le
20e sommet France-Afrique 49 pays
africains seront représentés et la
sécurité en Afrique sera un des grandes
thes des différentes réunions des chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement parmi lesquels
le président de la République
démocratique du Congo monsieur Kabila il
y a actuellement un lieu d'affrontement
violent c'est la région des Grands Lacs
à la limite du Congo et du Rwanda
Laurent désir Kabila utilise des anciens
membres des forces armées rwandaise de
l'ethnie Utu pour combattre l'armée
régulière du Rwanda celle-ci contrôle il
faut le rappeler un tiers du territoire
de la République du Congo 500000
personnes se trouvent ainsi déplacées et
ces personnes doivent participer à la
traque des houtou ancien participant du
génocide reportage dans la région des
Grands Lacs Philippe Rochot et daniel
Lévi il porent les mêmes bêches et les
mêmes machettes qui ont servi pendant le
génocide mais cette fois c'est pour
dégager les chemins de la frontière
entre le Congo et le Rwanda le Rwanda
veut empêcher les embuscades tendues par
les anciens miliciens génocidaires qui
se battent à présent au côté des forces
de
le nouveau maître du Congo l'armée
randaise est aujourd'hui engagée dans la
guerre au Congo car elle veut empêcher
les soldats de Kabila de venir jusqu'à
cette
frontière la sécurité était précaire ces
derniers temps mais la population s'est
désolidarisé des miliciens infiltrés et
elle assure elle-même sa
protection l'armé randaise est engagé
ici dans un double combatcre les
populations collaborer avec les
miliciens génocidaires réfugiés au Congo
et lutter contre les hommes de Kabila
qui veulent reconquérir les territoires
perdus jusqu'aux frontières du Rwanda
résultat cette région des volcans est
devenue la zone de déplacement de
population la plus importante d'Afrique
600000 personnes regroupées dans des
camps ou dans des villages comme celui
de
mousasabana les organisations
humanitaires viennent rarement ici à
cause de l'insécurité seul le Programme
alimentaire mondial achemine parfois de
la nourriture jusqu'à ce
[Musique]
village on a fu à cause des troubles
provoqué par les Infiltrés il voulaient
nous enrouler de force à leur côté mais
ici on a retrouvé la
sécurité une sécurité toute relative car
les anciens miliciens ou soutenus par
Kabila ne sont qu'à quelques kilomètres
d'ici régulièrement il lance des
attaques ou tente des embuscades tue et
vol il venait ici pour
kidnapp ou bien enlev les vaches ici au
Ronda pour aller les vendre au militaire
de kabida et puis il gagne des
cartouches ou bien des
B il vient ici au Ronda pour nous
attaquer le maire de Moussa Sabana
organisait ici un rassemblement pour
distribuer des semences aux paysans il
fait l'éloge de cette nouvelle armée
rwandaise qui protège les gens contre
les infiltrations des hommes à la solde
de Kabila mais tout peut
basculer hier c'était la guerre au qui
déstabilisa le Congo l'ancien zaï
aujourd'hui c'est la guerre au Congo qui
risque de déstabiliser le Rwanda ce qui
explique l'engagement de l'armée
randaise dans cette
région c'est à partir de là que les
soldats rwandais soutiennent les
rebelles du Congo résultat Kabila s
vengé contre une partie de sa propre
population qui s'est elle aussi réfugié
aux frontières du Rwanda 15000 personnes
s'entassent dans ce camp bien organisé
cette fois par le
HCR au Congo a fui l'arrivée des soldats
congolais dans son village pour se
retrouver ici il enseigne à ses enfants
réfugiés comme lui mais il ne veut pas
retourner chez
lui ils nous ont massacré ils ont pillé
tué les gens jusqu'à ce que n'avons plus
tenu nous n'avons plus eu le moyen de
résister nous
avons la rébellion congolaise est née
ASI dans camp de réfugiés de l'Est du
Congo qui ne veulent plus être contrôlés
par les soldats de Kabila aujourd'hui la
rébellion soutenue par le Rwanda et
l'ouanda contrôle le tiers du pays elle
s'estime en position de force pour
négocier tout l'est maintenant du du
pays c'est c'est nous qui contrôlons
cela hein nous avons récemment encore
pris Moba qui était la dernière ville
sur le lac Tanganika qu'il contrôlait et
nous avons pris bmba tout à fait sur euh
au bord du fleuve ce qui nous permet
d'arriver un peu plus vite à
Kinshasa les rebelles congolais et leurs
alliés du Rouanda auront pourtant du mal
à prendre Kinshasa mais ces populations
de l'Est du Congo veulent au moins être
représenté au sein du pouvoir dans la
capitale congolaise et ne plus être
méprisé par Kabila et ses hommes alors
seulement ces gens rentreront chez
[Musique]
eux